sony is still dealing with the fallout
from hackers who stole millions of pages
worth of documents including emails from
top executives health records of
employees private information about mega
movie stars and a whole lot more today
sony lawyers sent an official letter to
press outlets including Bloomberg News
telling us to destroy any documents that
we possess so let's bring in Brent Laing
he's a senior film reporter at variety
and no doubt Brent you pored over these
hundreds of pages of documents well yes
of course I mean they're very salacious
they're very embarrassing for top
executives in other words a dream come
true exactly for a journalist this is
it's Christmas came a little early but
is it Christmas coming a little early
because as Sony wants to say these are
documents that were obtained illegally
well I am being a little glib I mean to
be honest that this does raise a lot of
troubling ethical issues here you know
what is newsworthy what is just gossip
what is intended to embarrass and what
is intended to inform these are the
kinds of debates that I think newsrooms
all over Hollywood are but I think
everyone is ok with gossip it's what
sells
but this gossip was obtained illegally
so doesn't it make journalists who
promote it accomplices well that's a
very good point I think what everyone is
struggling with is you know how much do
you do you acknowledge the fact that
there's an ongoing debate about these
kinds of documents that these documents
being leaked are causing all kinds of
issues for top executives in Hollywood
without doing the work of guardians of
peace this hacker group that clearly is
out to undermine and and destroy the
credibility of top executives at Sony
and it's working it appear to be working
yes
although Sony seems to be trying to
control the narrative now that's why
this letter from lawyers that's why you
keep seeing in statements the repetition
of the phrase stolen documents they're
trying to emphasize that they are not
the villains here they are the victims
journalists are accessories to this kind
of thing all the time though people sign
non-disclosure agreements and then
promptly pick up the phone or arrange a
meeting with a reporter so that the
information that they want to make
public becomes public even if it's
subject to a legal agreement well a
great point that's journalism you're
trying to get information that people
often don't don't learn oh yeah exactly
this is just that kind of situation on
steroids exactly and there are some
legal precedents here there is a 2001
Supreme Court decision and which the
court ruled that a radio broadcaster had
the right to air a stolen illegally
obtained recording because they were a
third party they had not done the
illegal recording all right never shock
never short of having a few words Aaron
Sorkin wrote a piece and op-ed really in
the time today and I want to share a
piece quote if you close your eyes you
can imagine the hackers sitting in a
room combing through the documents to
find the ones that will draw the most
blood and in a room next door are
American journalists doing the same
thing as demented and criminal as it is
at least the hackers are doing it for a
cause the press is doing it for a nickel
well first of all I I do think it's
unfair he doesn't exactly know where
anyone was or what they were doing so
he's drawing a narrative or creating one
saying they're sitting in a dark room
but what do you make of it well Aaron
Sorkin as he acknowledges in this op-ed
has skin in the game he's one of the
people who's being discussed in some of
these emails in an embarrassing fashion
saying that he's you know desperate for
money trying to trying to sort of cut
corners and in that regard so he has
been one of the people who've been
victimized if you will in this case but
you know the the reality is that these
documents are getting out they're not
always going through journalistic
institutions and reputable journalistic
institutions still have a commitment to
the truth to accuracy to fairness and we
do reach out to to both sides we try to
acknowledge their perspectives differing
perspectives and that's where the press
has a role here I think how intense is
the debate in your news room at variety
it's very intense in fact our
editor-in-chief basically wrote an op-ed
last week saying it doesn't make me feel
great but I think it's right to do this
is it right to do this because I mean
how many years
riding around I am gonna fail that quiz
but decades decades is that
editor-in-chief saying I don't feel good
about it but it's right is the reason he
believes that is because in the last ten
years the likes of TMZ are taking a
tailor or eating your lunch well how do
you report on something like Scott Rudin
and Amy Pascal apologizing for racially
insensitive remarks without reporting on
the emails that contained those remarks
it's it's a quandary and we we cannot
you know pretend that these kinds of
discussions aren't taking place and we
owe it to our readers to have accurate
information that's a great point
furthermore the substance of the
reporting is exactly what reporters
would put in stories if they were able
to get it via other means absolutely if
you had sources at Sony who were privy
to some of this information maybe the
emails and related to you even read them
to you from paper or digital copies and
you felt that that source was credible
you take that information and put it in
a story in a heartbeat absolutely I
myself have obtained documents I wasn't
supposed to have that's journalism
that's reporting can I ask you what do
you think of this I think that this is
journalism like Brent says right this is
it how you come by the information
provided you didn't purloined it
yourself should in theory right in a
world of the First Amendment insulate
you from again I'm not a lawyer that I
would take now if I felt as though there
were a risk would I check with our
in-house counsel of course I would and
that's what we do and that's what you
guys have done of course yes does Amy
Pascal lose her job over this I mean
there are questions swirling around her
I think that the issue here is does that
establish a dangerous precedent do the
hackers win if you fire Amy Pascal no
look we know a lot more about Amy Pascal
and her relationships with people in the
industry that she would ever like us to
know however we're asking is she that
different from the other student read
these correspondents they are very
embarrassing but if you went through the
inbox of anyone in Hollywood there would
be embarrassing revelations nothing
in these emails as far as I can tell so
far appears to be a fireable offense
there's no kind of corporate malfeasance
or corruption in these messages how is
it though that people keep putting this
stuff in an email right we look at the
chatroom messages that the guys who
allegedly manipulated the foreign
exchange market what they've said and
the fart I mean it's far it's damning
for sure and it points the finger at
culpability but it's nowhere near as
clear as this I might if someone pulled
my email today there might be
embarrassing things on there that I
don't want the world to read but clearly
not this kind of content so couldn't
want to make the argument of studio head
how many people report to a studio head
hundreds well I think going forward you
will see people much more careful with
what haven't we been saying that for the
last four years
yes but different this time